[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman
whose family is walking away from her
after she married her new husband
we talked to a guy who's facing a
breakup after six years with the same
person
we talk about new year's resolutions
because it's the new year's eve show
stay tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john dolone's show
and good morning good afternoon good
night
hope you're doing well on this show we
talked about little health relationships
schooling parenting
figuring out life and i'm gonna walk
alongside you as we figure it out
together
if you want to be on the show go to
johndaloni.comaskask
or give me a shout at 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693
it is new year's eve
what are you doing listening to a
podcast
especially this one it's new year's eve
but alas
i will be listening to podcasts on new
year's eve too we're recording this one
in advance so on today's show we're
gonna take some calls and we're also
gonna talk about
my
recommendations for um new year's
resolutions i'm a big
resolve guy
and so we'll talk about that um on
today's show let's get right to the
calls though let's go to leslie in
burlington coat factory vermont what's
up leslie how are we doing
good morning dr john how are you this
morning so good how about you
i'm doing very well the sun is shining
life is good yes
we are out here our pets heads are
falling off what's up how can i help
i'm doing uh so i was looking for some
advice on how to handle some family
relationships in particular the one with
my sister okay some of the context is
that i recently got married last month
and i had been with my now husband for
just about six years
early on there was some conflict between
him and my family because he has some
strong conservative values and very
strong convictions in his faith and they
sort of attacked him for that um
my parents and most of my extended
family seeing that i was happy were able
to look past it and just see him for the
guy that he is
but some and some of my family in
particular my sister and a few cousins
who i was very close with before i
started dating him are sort of still
still holding on to that
um
not quite resentment but
you know for for lack of a better word
resentment um
it's now to the point where like
my sister won't talk to me refuses to
visit our house and essentially causes
drama any chance that she gets
any chances she gets if i'm being honest
um there have i've never really had a
good relationship with my sister but
it's definitely gotten exponentially
worse since i started dating my husband
um i
i don't want to assume any motive but if
i had to put my guess
i would think that it's partially
because my husband
really helped me find out you know what
my beliefs were and let me do my own
you know investigating and for my
forming my own opinions instead of just
you know whatever my family pushes me
into whatever box they assign me to sure
um what can i do to help rebuild and in
some cases build
these relationships back without having
to cave on my views and beliefs uh you
can't
um easy enough yeah
so you i mean you dated this guy for six
years and you knew
what your family thought of them
and you knew you thought of him and you
chose him
and so
as a result of your choice
family is now making their choices
and the challenge here is everybody's
got a
fantasy that they're trying to uphold
like i think in your heart and mind that
once they realize that no i really love
him and yes we see the world differently
but he's a good guy i'm a good person
and and and
then we'll all just go back to one big
happy family like on the tv shows
and they thought
oh we can't stand his beliefs and values
and he's annoying he's got a whatever
and whatever and fill in the blank
but once
once they get married they'll just be
fine and then everybody realized it was
exactly the same as before you're
married
and there so the fantasy is crumbling in
front of everybody
and then people respond to crumbling
fantasies in different ways
i tend to respond to them with a moment
of frustration and then just like i i
don't know i i don't know if it's
genetic or whatever i just move on like
you know or jocko he says like good like
it is what it is let's just move on to
the next thing other people spend the
next 40 years of their life
going to war over their picture of that
fantasy what our life should have been
and it doesn't feel right it doesn't
look right so it's your fault and it's
their fault and i'm going to create
drama and whatever
so really the thing you can do is treat
your sister with dignity and respect and
move on about your day because she's
chosen to not be in a relationship with
you anymore
because you chose to be in a
relationship with your husband right i
mean so it's just like a
as he said she said she said he said
i think you need to grieve the fact that
your family's opting out of you
is that hard
incredibly yeah it sucks huh
big time
like is what i'm saying resonating with
you
or am i out to lunch
no definitely definitely um it feels
like you've been holding your breath for
the last four or five years trying to
trying to make them all happy
and still love this guy
and truly become who you are in this
moment and you're by the way
i think every single person's beliefs
should change over time
that's why we read new books and
go to speeches and try new workout
programs and
create discipline in our lives so that
we learn new things and our beliefs
change but i think our values should
stay the same
meaning i will treat people with dignity
and respect i will honor my body and my
family and blah blah so
right now your beliefs are what they are
and you've chosen them good for you i'm
proud of you for having resolve and for
strength and that you've worked them out
on your own and with somebody who you
care about great
it just sucks when our family looks at
our values and who we want to become and
they're like uh i opt out that's hard
right
for sure and um
sort of what like
you know since i started dating him it's
definitely felt like i'm more of like
the black sheep of the family like my
cousin like like i said before i used to
be
very close with my cousins and now they
all have a group chat without me
and
they
you know make plans without me even if
it's in my area
and
i guess what was the kicker and kind of
led to all this kind of like
drama starting was
when my sister had
you know i had invited my sister up said
come up for dinner
like let's talk this all out
you know start fresh like let's play
everything on the table and she's like i
can't i'm busy
blah blah and then then that weekend she
had driven two hours past me to go on a
spontaneous adventure
and that just makes me think like okay
so you have time
to drive past me
to do this spontaneously
okay let's just say it out loud she
doesn't like you
that's fair
yeah it sucks it's hard but let's just
face that truth she doesn't like you she
doesn't want to be around you
so much so that she'll lie to you her
own sister
so much so that she will drive past your
house to go be with other people
and i think you need to spend some time
living in that reality
and if i was to be meeting with your
cousins right now on the phone if there
was like six of them all on the phone
calling me you know what they'd be
saying
we told her for five years and she chose
him over us and we're hurt by that
right and that's what you did and i'm
not saying that's right or wrong i'm
just trying to lay out the facts of this
thing
for sure so everybody's made their
choices they're big grown-up decisions
and
they've led everybody to
a place where they want to be in a
relationship with each other
you want the idea of a sister
but you don't like your sister you
haven't ever
is that right
that's putting it a bit strongly but in
so many words
okay yeah i mean you like the idea of
having a like ride or die sister that
you call and you talk about things and
when you get pregnant you're gonna talk
about that and
when your husband does something dumb
you got somebody and that's just not
gonna be your situation at least for the
time being
what i do think often these value
conversations
turn into
you're a scumbag
and underneath values conversations
especially political conversations
whether it's conservative or liberal
conversation and we just force the world
into these two options which is just so
stupid
um
it
can be values based but then it gets
into
hospitality base and that's where i
think both sides have issues
right i hate your idea so much i won't
be in your physical presence and i think
that's that's toxic and insane
and
i
hate this group of people or this way of
thinking or this way of being this way
of acting so much
i'm gonna cash out my family over it and
i think that's insane too
i think there's a third way
right but that's not where your family
is that's not where a lot of families
are and that's okay
um i think you've got to sit in the
reality
that your family doesn't want to be
around you
and and i'm not saying that trite i'm
seeing that with a broken heart for you
and then when you grieve that so all
grief is is the gap between what i
expected and hoped for and reality
that's grief i thought he would live
forever i thought she would quit
drinking i thought that he would only
cheat on me one time but he's done it
three times that
grief is just sitting in that gap for a
minute and then saying now what
and then now what will mean you still
have to have people in your life and so
you're gonna have to be about making new
friends people you can call and trust
and lean into you're gonna have to be
about reimagining what holidays are
gonna look like
you're gonna have to be about
reimagining what your relationship with
your sister's gonna be because you're
still gonna have to deal with mom and
dad you're still gonna they're getting
older all that kind of stuff you're
still gonna have to have a communication
even if it's just quick text messages or
emails or whatever but that's not for
right now right now it's just sitting in
the grief
your sister
thinks you chose him over them
and now they're moving on with their
life without you
i'm sorry
no it's definitely a a good way to put
it and um
i guess what's made this also
hard is that
my mom definitely tends to like
not put her problems on me but like
looks to me to
essentially solve her problems and this
has definitely been
a
big point of contention for her because
she wants me of course she does happy
family
like everyone does and it's just
so here's how you can handle that
you can tell your mom mom i love you and
i now have come to a place to realize um
i married my married
i'm gonna stay with him
i
right now believe the way i believe
and i'm gonna continue to be a searcher
continue to
look for um ways i can grow and learn as
we work through the world and that might
make you more conservative infinitely
more conservative i'm not trying to lean
you in a certain way saying this is just
who i am i'm gonna be somebody who's
always looking and
learning and asking questions and
meeting with new people but this is this
is our life i love you
i will always show up for dinner i'll
always be there
i'm not going to go to war with my
family
and if y'all choose other things without
me that's that hurts my feelings it
breaks my heart i'm going to choose to
allow that to break my heart and i
understand y'all are grown ups younger
to make those calls but i think it's
also fair after you grieve what what
comes after grief is boundaries
and after you lose a spouse you have to
decide what i will watch and what i will
look at and who i will hang out with
like you've got to really start to
create new boundaries that's where
you're gonna be
and you and your husband will co-create
those boundaries together we're just i'm
not i'm gonna quit reaching out to
sister other than on her birthday i'm
gonna send her something because i'm a
decent human being i am gonna send her a
text on her birthday i am going to like
i'll do i'll be human
um but i'm going to start doing the hard
work of finding new friends and that's
hard
i'm going to do the hard work of
controlling my thoughts and actions and
if she chooses to i'm not going to put
her into a situation even lied to them
anymore i'm going to move on from that
and i'm going to tell my mom mom i can't
solve all your problems i will be there
for dinner
and if you ask him to not come i'm not
going to come and because you're putting
me in a situation that um i i'm not i'm
not gonna be i'm not gonna play along
with
but yeah you gotta spend some time with
some grief it's hard you can't make
people like you and after six years you
made your choice
and again i'm proud of your convictions
i'm proud of your strength
and now you made your choices and then
we're going to live in the reality of
what those choices mean for you and for
those that you care about
i know it's hard
but we'll be with you stay tuned right
here on the dr john dolan show
all right let me clear up a common
misconception being tired all the time
is not normal and if you're always
exhausted take a good look at your
nightly sleep routine are you scrolling
the internet for hours or sharing a bed
with 17 animals and your spouse is your
mattress older than you listen the sleep
environment you create has so much to do
with how well you rest you've got to
protect it eliminate screens skip late
night snacks and have a bed you love
sleeping on like a dream cloud mattress
dream cloud is one of my favorite
mattresses because they're made of
premium sleep materials but they're half
the price of other premium brands they
also offer a 365 night trial and a
forever warranty to make sure you are a
hundred percent satisfied right now dr
john doloni show listeners get 250 bucks
off plus
399 in sleep accessories like pillows
sheets you name it
that's 649 dollars in savings not to
mention some deep deep rest if your
sleep routine needs resetting check out
dream cloud's biggest offer ever at
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code deloney
all right we are back flapjack jack
let's go to mitch in boise idaho mitch i
love that name what's up brother
good morning dr john how are you doing
good man how are you
doing okay thanks taking my call you got
it so what's up man
so
um
i um
in a relationship i guess you would say
at this point um
hold on man yeah you guess i would say
at this point sounds like y'all are
madly in love man
are you in a relationship or not in one
well let me explain
um several years ago
i started dating a woman and at first it
was long distance
um
as time went by she was able to move
closer
um we started become serious yeah
started talking about about marriage
and then you know
big things are children religion
and money
and so
we started doing things like traveling
to see
builders and architects she became very
nervous
when i sat down to talk about you know
my financial situation she
became very nervous
she would miss appointments to talk
about
her financial situation
and
it's just things got really weird really
quickly
how old is she
um she's probably in
her early 40s
how old are you
uh late 40s okay
has she been married before
um
no she has not have you
no i have not engaged not married okay
and then
at the end of all of this
it turns out that i didn't know who she
was and i mean that on all levels
i didn't know her parents i didn't know
where she grew up i didn't know where
she went to school i didn't know
um did she lie to you anything about her
yeah i didn't i didn't know her name
john
so she she was like living a lie all the
time
a very very
elaborate life whoa
and in the end
she
started having depression
alcohol abuse
suicidal ideation i'm trying to
work with her to get her treatment but i
want to move on yeah why
why
you're married i mean you're dating a
fraud
yeah i am
but i'm worried about her kids i'm
worried about her i'm worried about her
doing harm to herself
yeah i mean there's a there's a
humanitarian responsibility there which
i get and you need to put her in front
of professionals that can do that kind
of work
is just some i mean i'm speaking for you
maybe you realized everything was an
elaborate lie after all this time and
you're you're cool with it and you're
like oh it's cool shake it off we'll
i'll forgive you and then we'll let's
move on let's create something now under
reality i mean is that where you're at
are you on out of this thing
no i'm i'm done because i i tried that
once and then there were more things
came to life yeah dude i mean
this is heartbreaking because you
thought you were going to spend the rest
of your life with this woman have you
sat in that for a minute
yeah yeah like this sucks
yeah no i'm i'm
i mean i'm i want to move on but i don't
want to move on under a lie under the
next person without having
you know ended it with with this person
but i'm concerned if i ended with this
person she was going to end up
in a bad bad place yeah and she she
might be
um your responsibility is to treat her
with dignity and respect and to
call 9-1-1
it's not to
continue a
like a
janky
stumbly romantic relationship or
romantic relationship with somebody just
because you're trying to
like help her out that's not helping
anybody
in fact that's part of the ruse that's
part of the game is that she'll drag you
along and you become like a
like a leaky
oxygen tank for her until she can find
the next thing
damn
yeah man if you're done be done
with bold conviction
and she's made some choices she's got
some she's got some significant
challenges
yeah
yeah um but she took advantage of hell
yeah i've been together man
about six years now
damn
that's hard man
slicing my life on yeah yeah
and my hope is you can sit in that grief
for a season
and then look back and say even though
it was a lie you all had fun you did
laugh
right there was romance i mean it's not
with the person you thought and it's not
in the way you felt i mean the whole
thing i don't know dude that's hard man
yeah not even hard that's devastating
i'll just use that word
and you you have you ever listened to
the show
um
this show no i've heard you uh on uh the
rams okay
on the other shows um
so you probably haven't heard me say
this one of the most devastating things
about what you're experiencing
is a somebody lied to you and they
played a long game on you and that's
devastating it's unnerving
but what i find most often
is that mitch suddenly doesn't trust
mitch anymore
like how in the world did i miss this
and every new person you meet is this
big like well my signals were off last
time i don't know and it comes across as
you don't trust them
but often the the major distrust is in
you and it's unnerving because you don't
know which way to walk anymore because
you don't trust your feet anymore you
don't trust your eyes you don't trust
your heart you don't trust anything
anymore
and you gotta own that otherwise it just
will it will affect every new
relationship you're involved in
and you thought you won this one huh
[Applause]
like i could just imagine you 40 you're
44 you're 43
you're starting to think like man this
i'm just gonna be a single dude
and then you find somebody and then she
moves in and moves out and whatever and
then suddenly you're like you allowed
yourself to believe is that right yeah
yeah yeah it's a good way to sum it up
you're gonna slide into this deal under
50 have the last back half of your life
to ride or die with somebody and dude
she's a fraud i hate that for you man
i just don't want you to minimize that
and again i'm i'm speaking to you and
everybody listen i want you to minimize
how big of a deal this is this is heavy
yeah
so are you you're done done done
yeah yeah i mean there's no nothing to
build on when trust has been betrayed
over and over
in a huge way there's just no way to
build it from it so they all live
together
no so what does a breakup look like for
you
breakup would look like
a phone conversation
um
that can you do that in person no
uh
[Applause]
yeah probably could
probably shouldn't so here's what i
would recommend after six years of
somebody who's um
made a series of really unfortunate
character choices and is probably
struggling with a lot of
um
physical mental health challenges am i
right on both of those
yeah i think there's a lot going on
with her that
needs
she needs a lot of help okay
most of the time folks in this situation
create a breakup event
and it's got a lot of prelude and a lot
of talking and a lot of
hugging and crying and negotiating
and what i would recommend is putting
your thoughts in a letter
and
having an in-person conversation that is
on the whole very very short
with is this going to be a stunning
surprise to her surely she knows this is
coming in some shape form or fashion
well she knows i'm definitely not happy
with her okay i think that's part of
what's led to the alcohol abuse and et
cetera et cetera okay
um so and this is the same with when you
have to fire somebody this is the same
when you're breaking up with somebody
this is like
the conversation should be 15 minutes 10
minutes
this relationship is is officially done
um i am ending this relationship i don't
want to talk with you anymore if you
want to like my heart is in this letter
right here and here's what that does it
allow as soon as you say those words
boom her ability to think
critically is off she's in fight or
flight
so her thinking brain is off her
survival brain isn't full she will say
anything do anything and some of that
stuff will be true some of it will be
i'm so sorry and then it will get into
threats and i'm going to do this
if you write it in a letter she can go
back to it over and over and over and
over again
and she can't begin to misconstrue and
mischaracterize what you say and how you
set it
and so a very clear facts are your
friends
i'm standing at the doorway of a home
ma'am your husband was in a car wreck
today and he has died period
just like that
not well there was rainy outside it was
a darker storm nope here's exactly what
happened that's what i'm recommending
with you is to have an in-person
conversation
and let her know this conference i mean
if that's where you're going with it if
you get in that conversation and you
choose you want to stick with her great
um but i'd spend some time processing
that thing and then man
please go talk to somebody even if it's
once or twice just to get all of that
out because you got to rebuild some
trust with mitch man
okay
and if you think she's going to hurt
herself
make sure you've got 9-1-1 there or if
you need to have a social worker with
you or if she's got a
psychiatrist that you want to reach out
to
you can call her counselor her
psychologist or psychiatrist and say i'm
going to be terminating my relationship
with this person today or tomorrow they
can't call you back they can't even tell
you
that they're seeing her
but i don't know that yeah but they
can't take data one way
okay and they may know oh crap i need to
reach out and what you're doing there is
you're putting the impetus on the
professional
you are saying you are equipped to deal
with this i am not i'm not a suicide
expert i am not a crisis response expert
you are so here you go
i'm calling 9-1-1
and that's where your responsibility
lies there
and i know this sounds harsh and
clinical
um i don't want to see you get dragged
into the next nine months if i'm gonna
kill myself i'm gonna not kill myself
because you're not equipped to handle
that that's not your that's you don't
have the skill set to deal with that is
that fair yeah yeah that is that's true
cool
man i'm sorry brother
okay i'm sorry well i appreciate the the
direction anything else i can help you
with feel like it's a bummer call man i
don't know i wish i could have given you
like oh dude just say this it's gonna be
cool i
oh right but it sounds like you call
like you already know man
[Music]
i oh yeah i mean i i knew i knew it
wasn't going to i don't know get better
just trying to find a way to to
take my life back
yeah
yeah
well dude i i'll walk with you you want
to call back after this thing's
like the smoke clears a little bit and
like now what's next man i'm happy to
walk with you on on that side of it too
[Music]
okay
all right all right
thank you very much all right brother
i'm grateful for you mitch we'll be
right back on the dr john delaney show
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back on this man
suddenly left turn depressing new year's
new year's eve show it's not depressing
it's just reality so
here's here's a way we can segue
the the two calls so far today
they've got to face reality
they got to face reality here's the
world there in
previous color mitch is like six years
he was lied to just completely
bamboozled and here's reality he's done
with this relationship and now it's next
and before that leslie in burlington
like man
she made a choice on who she's going to
marry
and
she's got a choice on her beliefs and
her family said well then we're out and
bam she's sitting in that reality and
again you've heard me start to say this
a little bit but
we live in a culture that's one of two
we just force people in these these
binary choices either
you know you got no
feelings just go do right
and
you got the other side of it which is
how do you feel how do you tell us about
your feelings how do you feel
and
if you don't feel it you do you yolo
what whatever
and i think both of those are nonsense
the path forward for all of us
is both and it's a third way it's a
third path it's acknowledging the
stories you're born into the ones you
were told
acknowledging reality
and
now what
now what
what you can do now what are you going
to do now and that brings us to new
year's ma'am my favorite time of the
year
since i was a little kid i love new
year's and i talked about this last year
i just think it's hilarious that as a
culture we all just
give each other a mulligan no matter
what you can just
well i gained 811 pounds well
man
i tried crack a few times and now i'm
all like whatever the thing is and it's
like new year's resolution time and
everyone's like sweet cool like control
delete let's do it
i actually started mainlining twinkies
well i'm off new year's great
so that's where we're at
so the other day i was hanging out with
my buddy
dr conway jp conway the dude's he's
brilliant he's not as smart as his wife
dr conway she's
way smarter but he's pretty smart
and man we were talking about
resolutions and new year's what this
looks like and he gave me a framework
that i've never heard of before it's not
complicated or savant-ish or anything
but it's what i'm using this year so
i'll pass along my news resolution
framework and then i'll give you a
little bit of idea of what i'm doing
so here's the framework
identity who are you
body and mind
money
time
talent
that's it
identity body and mind money time and
talent
and so i start with identity i love how
james clear talks about this and um it's
it's proven in my life to be profound
when i'm trying to change behaviors i'm
trying to change habits i'm trying to
change the way i look at the world i
start with identity instead of starting
with goals
start with dude who am i who are you and
so here's a question i want you to
answer for 2022 coming up
who are you going to be in 2022 who are
you who are you going to be
here's what i wrote i'm a funny joyful
guy
i'm peaceful and patient
those are four things this past couple
years i've let slide
like man i used to just be a fun guy to
be around and i'm all like drama and
serious
let's listen to old metal okay man i
need to cheer up
the world sucks i want to cheer up we
need more joy and more smiling does that
mean i'm going to become a naive idiot
no
but that means if i've got a chance to
tell a joke i'ma tell it that means if
i can be a little more patient with
somebody who's working really hard on my
behalf i'm gonna be more patient that
means i want people who are exp or in my
presence to leave a little more peaceful
than when they got there and that starts
with me being a person of joy
uh i have adventures i say yes
and
we've gotten back into that this year
but man that's all about the adventures
what's the craziest thing we could do
right now
do you want to fight jim yep want to go
on a crazy hunting trip yep i want to go
yep i meant and then i just got old put
on a tie
started going to work every day like
and i'm all about working hard yeah but
man i'll be about the adventure
i'm gonna i'm gonna be willing to lose a
couple hours of sleep for a great story
i'm gonna be willing to
like we talked about a couple shows ago
shoot a deer a mile into the woods and
figure out later how to get it out right
i i want to be about the adventure
i'm invested
i am an invested in world-class husband
and father
i want to be good at being a dad i want
to be good at being a husband and that's
going to frame some of my activities
i'm a hospitable neighbor
man i was on the road a lot this year i
want to be better about knowing my
neighbors i'm going to be better about
when they think hey i need some help
with i can call that guy
just being a guy in my community that
people can think
i trust that guy let's give him a shout
he'll show up
and then people are less anxious after
being in my presence that goes back to
the top one but i want to be i've just
been around some folks i've been around
y'all and been around some folks you're
in their presence and your heart rate
drops
and i want to be that for folks i think
that's what the world needs right now is
a little less third rail
body of mind i'm gonna do one hard thing
a day that's pretty normal for me
whether it's like man chipping the ice
out of the cold tub yesterday
man it was cold taking cold showers my i
worked out outside today it was freezing
like what i would do one hard thing a
day there is some days that i skipped
that i'm not gonna do that this year
um exercise workout movement every day
i'm gonna i gotta download an app 365
days i'm not gonna skip a day of moving
my body i'm not gonna have my goal for a
day be to do nothing
now that doesn't mean i'm gonna go
insane every workout doesn't mean i'm
not gonna have days where i
don't um
devote some time to some maintenance and
taking care of myself and
but
i'm going to every day i move my body
every day i'm going to exercise work out
i'm going to do something towards
continuing to honor my body
um this year i think i'm going to hit
right at 50
books read for the year it's good it's
fine it's fine it's good but i wrote a
big book and that took a ton of time
writing a book is hard um and i'm
excited the book comes out this year i'm
super jazzed about it but this year i'm
going to move them up to 75 books i'm
not gonna have a book to write i'm gonna
be traveling a lot speaking and being on
the road with this new book and coming
out to y'all's town since i'm excited
for that but 75 books this year it's for
my mind
um
much man i got sucked into an office
vortex this year
man i've watched more tv in the last
seven months and i have probably lost
three years
man i'm done with that done with that
i'm gonna get back out i do love the
office it's a show that just it's like a
xanax for me but i'm i'm out um more
games i got some guitars that i'm
working on fixing i'm gonna hunt a
little bit more and we are making a
garden that's about the size of a small
planet at our on our place and so i'm
looking forward to that money um i've
got a
really audacious salary goal for this
year an obnoxious one i'm gonna have to
work really hard and what i'm gonna do
is i put i put that number down and then
i'm gonna reverse engineer it here's how
much i got to make each month here how
much i gotta make each week and then
we're gonna reverse engineer we're gonna
fill those gaps in that way
um
i'm gonna try to pay off my house this
year it's gonna be hard hard hard that's
a stretch goal but figure it out um i've
got a giving amount that's gonna be
obnoxious an obnoxious giving amount
um and we're gonna save and then i fell
off this year just with the
homeschooling and the back in school and
the huh
man it got to where doing budgets with
my wife was just our quiet time you know
going over calendars and bunches and i
gotta bring my kids back into that they
need to see that struggle they need to
see how much things cost they need to
see their role as as a an important part
of our home
and i'm not going to give them all the
details but they do need to know how the
world works and that starts with them us
me and my wife modeling budgeting and
then time dude i just waste a lot of
time i gotta slow
down i've got to be present
um
i just gotta stop wasting time so i'm
gonna do a time audit over the next
couple of days and really dial it in i
think i know i can get an hour or two
back each day and i'm looking forward to
that and then talents man what are the
things i'm good at that i
mean james playing music this year
i needed that that was good for me you
play every week huh you played for your
church
not quite every week but every couple
weeks see i just i don't i i need to
start playing
um
and i want to be better at speaking and
obviously the book's coming out this
year and then i've doing some stuff with
my local community with the police
officers here in town and getting back
and doing some crisis stuff the right
crisis calls that gives me life and it's
something i'm good at so there's some
personal things in there and some more
specific data points in there for this
year but going back to
identity
body and mind
money time and talents that's the
framework i'm using this year from dr
conway
i recommend you use that framework give
yourself some sort of framework and then
here's the magic
tell somebody
sit down and read this out loud grab a
couple of guys bring them over y'all
grab some beers and you'll say here's
what where's i'm committing to this year
here's what y'all are committing to if
you want to be gangster put 500 bucks in
a pot
i'm gonna run this marathon i'm gonna
save this much money i'm gonna earn this
much money i'm gonna exercise every day
and if i don't this pot goes to
the
charity of your choice
the charity i hate the most in the world
whatever like put something in there
right i've seen guys like you can start
a workout program they take pictures of
each other and if they quit working out
then they're gonna post the other guy's
picture whatever the thing is for you
bring some women over your house y'all
all hang out and say hey let's be
vulnerable here's what i'm gonna work on
here's i'm gonna work on being a mom
this year i'm gonna work on being a wife
this year i'm gonna work on a girlfriend
this year whatever that looks like for
you
um
and then by the end of the year we're
gonna reverse engineer that so i want
two finished guitars at the end of this
year that means i gotta build that on my
calendar i wanna actually take my family
on vacation this i'm gonna work it in i
want this hunting trip i'm gonna work
that in and then we're gonna have an
incredible intentional
year
the magic here is identity and
intentionality
we just think our problems are just
gonna go away
if we just ignore them they'll stop if
we just quit talking about it in our
mirrors it'll just fix itself
we want better sex we it'll just happen
it'll just happen i want to talk to my
kids better it'll just they're just in a
phase they'll grow out of it i want to
make more money and my boss will just
one day be like you know what 40 raised
for you
i just want
they don't just go away
it's about identity and about
intentionality
and i'm with you i'm going first i want
you to join us so if you're a real
baller i want you to write down your
new year's resolutions
mail them to me
and we will put the physical address
here in the show notes and over the
course of the year i'm going to reach
out to you and see how you're doing on
them
this is the ultimate bluff call 2022
bluff call the world needs you to step
up the world needs you to lean in here
let's get it done all right as we wrap
up today's show
it's off the dr feelgood album
i love that record
james can we be honest
playing the crew was fun huh
that was probably the most fun song to
play yeah song james did we think we
didn't even play it because we didn't
make the finals because we weren't that
good
i gotta bring that up here on this show
about change the song is called time for
change
and it goes like by the crew and it goes
like this
i heard some kids telling me how they've
lost all the faith
in the way
they've been talking world peace and the
wars in the streets the lines on their
faces so deep a revolution or reach out
and touch the day were overdue child
change now it's time for change nothing
stays the same
i feel the future in the hands of our
youth
no more lies old tired fools tell our
future with tarot cards and live crime
the lines on their faces so deep a
revolution i reach out and touch the day
we're overdue
it's time for change nothing stays the
same it's time for change let's all
change together identity
intentionality let's do this i'm going
first i hope you're with me we'll see
you soon on the dr john delaney show